all right
good evening members welcome to the
development committee of rochefort
district council on the
22nd of october 2010
first of all apologies for absence
they've been received from councillor
mr shaw who has been substituted for by
councillor gooding
and from councillor mrs weston who's
been substituted by
councillor steptoe um so that covers one
and
two non-members attending i've noted
councillors wilkinson
rowe whatton sparring and dre
that's all of you yeah thank you
um minutes of the meeting held on the
24th of september 2020
um i will assume that you are happy for
me to sign those
as a correct and accurate record unless
you
indicate by showing your hand i'll just
wait a moment
thank you i have no indication so in due
course those will be signed
item five is to receive declarations of
interest we have counsellor
steptoe first mr chairman
uh with reference to item six uh i'm a
member of the
uh essie's county council thank you
councillor thank you chairman just to
note that i'm a member of riley town
council thank you
councillor dre thank you chairman
um item six seven and eight as a member
of raleigh town council
although i'm not on the planning
committee thank you thank you
counts the sparing
you need to unmute please
try it try again counselor sparing we
missed it
sorry chairman uh again a member of
ready town council but another member of
this committee
thank you right okay thank you very much
so we move on to
item six which is land to the rear of 98
and 128
high street rayleigh again there is
information about
this application on the addendum
so please make sure you refer to that
and i think katie rogers is going to
present on this one please
thank you i'll just share my screen with
you
so hopefully on screen you can see the
location plan
so members this application is for
redevelopment of the for
former dairy quest site the site is a
backlash on site access between
buildings fronting the high street
in rayleigh town centre the site board
is a library to the west
an area of the playing field associated
with a school
um the garden and site of a residential
dwelling number 7a
crown hill and to the east the site
board is a car park associated with a
commercial premises
on screen now is the layout plan
so two buildings are proposed
which would be positioned either side of
a central
open space two commercial units are
proposed one in each building at ground
floor and they would be positioned here
and here either side of the central
access
otherwise the buildings will be in
residential use
this is a revised proposal following
refusal of a previous scheme on four
grounds which the applicant has sought
to address
in respect of the previous reason for
refusal relating to
inadequate car parking provision the
scheme would now ensure that all spaces
would meet the preferred base size of
2.9 by 5.5
and the spaces will be provided in a
court here three spaces in the central
area here
and then some adjacent part of the
southern boundary
at least one parking space per flat will
be provided and one space for each of
the commercial units
and this level of on-site provision in
this town centre location which has good
access to public transport
is considered acceptable there is also a
reason for refusal of the previous
scheme relating to air quality let's
take you to this plan here
take it down a bit
so the plan on screen you can see
is the plan associated with the air
quality management area order
and my arrow is now pointing hopefully
you can see that
about centrally to the small bit of
building within the site which is within
this red line
so as part of the site is within this
area the whole site is regarded as being
subject to this order
however other than the at this location
the air quality management area is the
only is only one building deep
off the high street along its full
extent or off
the other roads that are associated with
this order
members will note on the addendum that a
further consultation response has been
received regarding air quality
with confirmation that the inclusion of
this small section of the dairy quest
site
within the air quality management area
boundary is anomalous
and that the proposed residential flats
would not be subject to poor air quality
given the step back from the high street
the flats would be shielded from
vehicles using high street and taking
account of the rapid drop off of
pollution with distance
this site should not be considered at
risk of poor air quality
the development would just go back to
the layout plan
so it would give rise to additional
vehicle movements onto high street and
therefore
within the air quality management area
and the applicant has proposed mitigate
mitigation by way of the installation of
electric
vehicle charging points i'm just going
to zoom in to this plan here
just to show you on the plan
just in one area of the site at least um
so these um
six they're not all shown here because
some are to the other parking spaces
but they're denoted with these red red
dots here
all the other bays will be future proof
to enable installation of further
equipment at a later date
without the need for major ground works
members also raised concern with the
previous scheme with regard to the
appropriateness of the pros vehicular
and pedestrian
access to the site i'm just gonna move
that layup plan around so you can see
the access off high street
changes to the proposed layout so in in
this area where my cursor is here
in particular would discourage parking
on the access road that leads to the
turning head um because people wouldn't
generally park
blocking in a designated bay
refuse and delivery vehicles would
therefore have the ability to enter and
exit the site in forward gear
following further discussion with the
applicant the recommendation would now
remove condition 17 and incorporate this
requirement to resurface this access
the whole of this area here here
um into a legal agreement with two heads
of terms
and these would be a requirement for
resurfacing of the vehicular and
pedestrian access to the site
beyond the adopted highway which is
approximately here
in accordance with details to have been
submitted and agreed to the local
planning authority
and these details are to include
delineation of the foot
way in a different surfacing material or
collar along this extent here
and the resurfacing will be required to
be carried out prior to first occupation
at the site
in addition a requirement will be
included for a parking management
strategy
to discourage parking on the access of
the site particularly in this area
here and again this would be required to
be implemented prior to first occupation
if members were to resolve the grant
planning permission for this application
tonight the section 106 would have to be
signed
before any planning consent were issued
and the inclusion of these requirements
in the 106 would secure the delivery of
an appropriate pedestrian and vehicle
access to the site
just going to zoom out on this plan a
bit
and move it up
so concern was also raised in relation
to the previous scheme with regard to
the impact on the residential amenity of
this dwelling here number seven
a crown hill and the previous scheme
proposed a u-shaped building which had a
wall which extended right along the
boundary
um adjacent um to the boundary with 7a
the revised proposal for two separate
buildings
would reduce the extent of built form
and create this break in the built form
in the center of the site
the scale of the building closest to 7a
would now be two-story
as would um this part of this other
building
um which is adjacent to the boundary
with this residential property
let's take you to the this is the first
floor plan i mean it's also sort of
facing
northward so my cursor is in the
position where the garden of 7a
extends adjacent to the boundary so
windows are proposed to the first floor
in the side elevation of both buildings
which would face this boundary
and the plan on screen shows these
windows so here and here
here and here and and there and they
serve a lounge sort of kitchen
and shared space all of these windows
will be required to be obscure glazed
and fixed shut below 1.7 meters
from finish for law level so whilst
these windows would let in light
they would not give rise to potential
for overlooking and loss of privity
privacy to 7a
and the same obscure glazing requirement
would be imposed on
the second story element which would
only be this this part here
which is adjacent to the boundary with
the um the school
um playing field this balcony here
so in this first floor um will be
provided with a louvre detail across its
full width which would prevent
overlooking towards number 7a
um and other balconies on so here where
my cursor is and here on the other
building
would be orientated such as not to give
direct views over to the private garden
area of this neighbouring property
[Music]
sorry let me just take you to the
elevations
so on on screen at the elevations of the
building proposed to the eastern part of
the application site
when it pops back on screen yep um the
elevation in the bottom left hand corner
of the screen
here um is that which would be adjacent
to the rear of number 7a
and the existing boundary wall would
obscure the ground floor windows
it would be these first floor windows
that will be visible
and they would all be obscure glazed and
fixed shut above the 1.7 meter height
apologies i'm going to take you to the
section plan now
so this is a section through the site
and the one at the bottom of the screen
is section
a a so that's taken here where my cursor
is
and so you can see the dwelling 7a in
the left-hand side
and then it's across the site
so it does show that the closest part is
is now two-story
um and again there's another section so
the next section is bb
so that other one um and this section is
taken through the three-story part of
the other building
but it's this three-story part would not
be adjacent to the boundary with this
neighboring property that would be
adjacent to the school playing field
i'm going to show you the phone
this photo on screen is the side
elevation of number 7a and the area of
rear garden between the rear elevation
and the existing boundary wall
and beyond that it's the two-story part
of the proposed building which would be
visible
directly
the next photograph is just turning in
the other direction
um to show the this in this area of my
cursor is here
um there would be an the two-story
element to the other building proposed
and then beyond that
um it would rise to three story
the elevation plans on screen are of the
proposed building which will be sighted
towards the west at
western sorry it will pop back in a
minute
western part of the site concern was
raised in relation to the previous
scheme regarding the appropriateness of
the design and form in relation to the
context of the site
particularly i'm sorry partly within and
otherwise immediately adjacent to the
conservation area
the design and form of the proposal has
changed significantly
the pitch roof form with gaber lens
would now reflect the traditional
vernacular and nearby buildings noted to
be of design merit
adjacent to the site i'm fronting the
high street
i'll show you an image that the
applicant has submitted
so this image is provided to aid in
understanding how the proposed
development would be viewed in relation
to the existing
nearby buildings in the conservation
area within the high street
and you'll see the image in the bottom
right hand corner here
is how the buildings to the western side
of the site will be viewed
and down the existing axis
following publication of the addendum
the lead local flood authority have
confirmed that they're happy to
recommend planning conditions in
relation to surface water drainage
satisfy that an appropriate surface
water drainage scheme can be provided
a minute in addition i can confirm that
the payment towards mitigation
relating to protection of ecologically
sensitive coastal areas of the district
has now been made
in conclusion then the scheme has been
amended significantly from that
previously considered and refused
it is considered that the revisions have
addressed previous concerns and the
recommendation is therefore one of
approval
subject to the heads of term of a
section 106 legal agreement
as detailed in my presentation including
the omission of condition 17
and subject to the amended condition as
detailed on the addendum
the surface water drainage conditions
indicated in the published report
as heads of conditions would be those as
per the consultation response now
received
from the lead local flood authority
thank you
thank you we have two statements to be
read out before we get to our discussion
the first is from
mr glynn friend who is the agent sonia
please
thank you chairman um so statement from
mr glenn friend
uh the planning agent um thank you for
reviewing this scheme
at committee tonight and listening to
this statement
since the previous application that was
seen by the committee in december of
last year
2019 we have worked closely
with rochford district council planning
department
to develop the revised scheme you see
before you here tonight
we have taken on board comments raised
at the previous development committee
meeting and held two consultation
evenings
inviting counsellors and residents to
drop by
and comment on the proposals to take the
scheme forward
based on both comments from the above
and working closely with the council
we went back to the drawing board and
redesigned the scheme from first
principles the key issues that have been
addressed are as follows
we've addressed the number of units on
site and reduced this to initially
26 units this allowed us to accommodate
the correct number of parking spaces on
the site
providing one space for every
residential unit
together with one space each for the
commercial units
and several for visitors looked at the
design of each block
and used the existing site surrounding
buildings
in the high street and use of
traditional materials
to inform the visual character of the
proposed buildings
proposed materials are similar brickwork
to that predominantly found on the site
integrated with elements of painted
timber cladding
and render as can be found locally
finished with pitched
tiled roofs this has all been brought
together
to echo the surroundings in a
contemporary manner
ensured that the refuse vehicle will be
able to gain
access to the site and turn within the
site to exit and afford
gear whilst addressing pedestrian safety
into
and out of the site ensured that
principles sought by essex county
council
people places team were still integrated
into the scheme
there is a key focal point within the
scheme that is visible from the high
street
with a strong landscape scheme enhancing
the development
and helping form a sense of place
security is being considered with the
buildings themselves helping to provide
self-surveillance of the external areas
and car parking
with the view to look to comply with
secured by design
standards address concerns
from neighbours to ensure overlooking
has been designed out of the scheme
notably towards
7a crown hill
we now have a scheme that has 24
residential units reduced by a further
two
we have parking base to the preferred
essex county council sizes being
2.9 times 5.5 meters
every apartment has one space both
commercial units have one space and
there is a couple of spaces left over
for visitors
it is intended that during the day the
spaces towards the northeast of the site
adjacent to the gym could be used by
visitors during certain times of the day
when the skate spaces could be left
vacant by residents and visitors
we've also developed the design to
incorporate physical features that will
address
any potential overlooking of 7a crown
hill
whilst also picking up on comments
raised by
essex county council places for people
team and incorporating more soft
landscaping and green features into the
fabric of the buildings themselves
the new scheme has green credentials at
its core
within the car parking areas we're
providing 12 spaces with access to
electric car charging points
from the point the development will be
ready for occupation
every space in the car park will be
future proofed
and have the infrastructure in place to
provide electric car
charging if needed the whole development
is intended to be serviced by electric
only
no introduction of gas spoilers is
intended
to supplement the electrical
requirements photovoltaic cells have
been allowed for on the roof
the reduction in units reduced parking
encouragement for use of electric cars
and the avoidance of fossil fuel boilers
on site
all help to address the concerns raised
about the impact of the air quality
management zone
added to this the additional landscape
features of which help to
catch and filtrate airborne particulate
will all address the air quality within
the vicinity of the site
in summary we hope you can see the
efforts put in by the design team
and planning officers to come up with a
design that is a positive move forward
that addresses
all of the previous concerns and reasons
for refusal
the scheme is now stronger greener and
will provide a positive contribution
to the town and as such hope that you
can support this scheme that will
provide
much needed one and two bedroom
properties in a sort after town centre
location
thank you thank you
and we go straight on to the second
statement from mr
russell brown as an objection
thank you um this development would be
severely
detrimental to our home it would cause
significant loss of light and privacy
during the winter it will block out most
of the morning sunlight
it is just as overbearing as the
previous proposal
and causes a comparable amount of
overshadowing
this severe overshadowing is one of the
grounds on which the previous proposal
was refused i'm going to explain why
this development produces such bad
overshadowing it's due to its proximity
height and location firstly it's very
close
located directly behind the current
boundary wall
secondly it's very high our property
stands on land 1.5 metres lower than the
dairy crest site
during the winter an extra 1.5 meters in
height
causes more than three extra meters of
shadow
even at noon thirdly the building is
located directly to the south
east it is almost ideally placed to
block out as much of the morning sun
as possible the current proposal has
changed in several ways from the
previous proposal
however the way it affects our home has
not changed significantly
previously the closest part of the
building was two and three stories high
with flat roofs in the current proposal
the whole of the closest part is two
stories high
with a pitched roof so although one part
of the proposal has been lowered
another part has been raised due to the
pitched roof
what kind of effect will a building of
this size and location have
upon our property the architect's sun
path analysis
diagrams are incorrect and unhelpful
they place the new building in a
different position from their other
plans
pushing it further away from our house
their diagrams don't take into account
the height difference between the two
sites they show the light at dawn and
noon
but nothing in between i would like to
show a more representative diagram
which hopefully you can see on screen
this shows the shadows cast by block b
of the development on the 6th of
november at 10 30 a.m
the date has been chosen as the midpoint
between the equinox and the winter
solstice
for three months of the year the shadows
will be worse than shown here
the shadows at this time of day will
still block light to most of the lower
windows
the shadows almost totally cover the
back garden
and reach as far as the windows upstairs
the diagram clearly shows that the
overshadowing of the house continues
well into the morning
again for three months of the year the
shadows will be longer than this
overall i believe the overshadowing
produced will be similar
to the unreasonable overshadowing which
caused the previous proposal
to be rejected as well as our light our
other immunity would be significantly
reduced by this proposal
most of the view of the sky from the
rear of our house
will be replaced with a view of a
building 20 meters long
and 14 meters high for reference
the current wall is 4.5 meters high
we would also lose the warmth of the sun
and the privacy at the rear of our
home which is currently not overlooked
there have been attempts to reduce the
overlooking produced by this proposal
but serious problems remain for example
three rooms at the rear of our home will
have views of the balconies on the
northeast
face of the building someone standing on
the closest balcony
will be able to turn their head and look
down into a bedroom or the kitchen
we're also concerned about flooding land
near to
site is often saturated due to the
higher water table
any extra water allowed to run off into
the ground
will almost certainly make this worse
our home
together with other houses on crown hill
and half of the dairy
site are all part of the conservation
area the residential buildings within
the conservation
area on crown hill are smaller than the
buildings on the high street
the two areas are currently separated by
low-rise
backlands typical of the historic
structure of the town
placing large buildings on this land
breaks up the second
separation between the high street and
the lower density residential area
on crown hill therefore this development
represents a major change in the
character of the
conservation area in summary the
proposed development is too big
and too close it will be severely
detrimental to our immunity
significantly reducing the light and
privacy at the rear of our home
it will negatively affect the character
of the conservation area
it will cause unreasonable overshadding
equivalent to that caused by the
previous proposal
for these reasons i believe the
application be refused
thank you for listening to my statement
thank you um
could you unshare your screen now please
katie
thank you um have a counselor
wilkinson first
thank you chair and with the respect can
i
ask katie to re-share what she's just
had on the screen
gem with your permission because i
wanted to make reference to it that's
okay
um particular that particular particular
yeah that particular
um document that was there yeah um
members chairman members i um i'm here
this evening um
and i'm going to concentrate uh on the
occupants of number 7a and the impact of
this development on 7a that's really
primarily why i'm here
i think it's important to address first
of all uh or to note first of all that
not only
has the developer but the the officers
as well have
have really made um great attempts to
try and rectify all the issues that were
that were present at the last
uh the last hearing and the reasons for
refusal
um however and my submission to you will
be that that's
because of um the issues raised by mr
brown in respect of 7a
i don't think it's gone far enough um
those of you who were present uh with me
and
katie and several others uh at the
beginning of august
at the site visit would remember the
what the weather was like then it was a
lovely hot summer's day we were all
dressed
for the beach and after we left the site
we went
round the corner to the back garden of
number 7a we've seen the photographs
that katie showed us and i'm sure that
you remember
the large one and a half meter concrete
plinth on which that wall
sits it's a slight um if you haven't
seen it in person
that photograph sort of gives it away a
little bit that it looks like
the wall is higher than it is it's
actually a normal sized wall
single size wall on a one and a half
meter plinth
um now i don't know if you remember uh
then the
the ground at that time was sodden
um it was quite wet the patio area
and with this is why i wanted this
diagram up if you look at the
at the the shaded area there and you can
see where it says seven and there's a
little dog leg that sticks out
that dog leg and just just the left of
that is where their back door is and
there's a large very large patio area
there and i don't know if members
remember that
and we all congregated on there there
was a table and um mrs brown put some
drinks out for us
the patio was absolutely covered in moss
it was damp and covered in moss and that
was on an august day a hot
august day and now the reason
for the the the um the water issues in
that property
um are when that property was built the
ground had to be excavated to level the
land
thereby taking it the meter and a half
lower which is why it's lower than the
theory crest site
and taking it that much closer to the
water table it's struggling
to deal with water surface water at the
moment
and that's with the amount of sunlight
that it has to dry the ground
um this situation that you can see there
is going to exacerbate it
tenfold because it's going to pretty
much no sunlight
direct sunlight on that patio at all
i think it's important to note that
this site needs to be developed it is a
derelict
it's it's an eyesore and it needs
something doing to it
irrespective of the fact that i think
most of us agree that there's no
no proper vehicle or access we're not
going to get around that it does need to
be developed
but it needs to be developed
appropriately and it needs to be
developed sympathetically with regards
to the neighboring properties
7a is now included within
the rainy town conservation area because
of the updated plan of 2010.
therefore duragard has to be given to an
impact on that property as well as other
properties within the conservation area
um i would strongly suggest
that this property is too high
sorry the development is still too high
and as a result is casting the
overshadowing and it's overbearing
um it's an overbearing balkan mass and
chairman i would respectfully ask you
and the committee to please reject it
on the basis of the bulk and mass of the
building at the moment
thank you thank you
councillor dre
thank you chairman uh can i start by
supporting the comments of
councillor wilkinson particularly with
regards to
7a crown hill my own feeling is that
notwithstanding the information given us
to
given to us regards to addendum i
personally am still concerned regarding
the overlooking
and privacy issues of 7a crown hill
and the overshadowing the garden area in
my view
mr chairman it would clearly cause a
loss of amenity
to the residents also mr chairman i'm
concerned
and surprised that there are no further
comments
from essex highways particularly
following
the latest site visit my own feeling is
that
access and exit to and from the site
will be difficult for vehicles
especially turned whilst turning right
into the site from the high street
and also bearing in mind the very close
proximity
to the mini roundabout at the junction
of eastwood road and the high road
a high street sorry also there's a
recommendation
a planning recommendation uh con
planning condition
3.58 on page 6.22
in my view mr chairman that would not
discourage
ad hoc parking within the vehicular and
pedestrian access to the site
particularly once the retail units
become operative thank you mr chairman
thank you um
with the screen i'm seeing i've not
noted
any other non-members wishing to speak
okay right we'll now move up the
discussion on to members counselor mrs
shaw
thank you chairman it's i appreciate
the agent and developer really looked at
our concerns
on this um but my concern is
the getting in and out of the properties
that they're going to be built i do
agree that i think
there's going to be too much
overshadowing on it
and i've noted the um parking spaces
have gone for
to 2.9 times 5.5 meters
but there isn't one disabled space in it
which should be
3.6 minimum width and they're my
concerns thank you
thank you councillor stanley you've
indicated
thank you chairman um first of all i've
got to ask
what happened to our uh although we had
a discussion with the
uh officer uh on the
on the plans and we were supposed to be
informed
as to how that was progressing and what
they was going to do
i'm a bit annoyed to find out that i
haven't i haven't been told and i don't
think any of the committee have been
told anything
other than what is written down at the
moment and it's been a long time
getting there this is the last almost
the 11th hour when i got it and had to
read through it and he still didn't give
me what i wanted
however having said that
i do agree with uh councillor wilkinson
and also i would like to know what
provisions have been made for
all the water that will end in the site
will be delivered in the site and where
it will
go that was one of my
big questions which i haven't found an
answer to
so in that respect and also
the parking bays at the rear of the
premises
to uh super drug and and
snooker and what have you
there could be a misunderstanding there
for the people that are going to use
that uh facility in parking
in areas where residents
where where it's been put for residents
so if a residents come
if a resident comes back and he wants to
put his car in he's got in that car
space he can't do so and there could be
repercussions on that
also the two parking spaces
at the uh which is supposed to be the
commercial
uh premises on the to the right of that
drawing
they're not actually theirs to
to turn around and say they can park
there
um that is not their sight i do believe
unless unless the officer can tell me
that it is their site
and they have control over those two
parking spaces
i don't believe they have the site is
only
the dairy site not the road not those
two spaces
so therefore i don't think i can support
these this
application thank you councillor eves
yeah um i do support
uh the comments made by all councillors
so far um although i
do commend the developers for trying to
actually address
the the concerns that we have i still
feel that we have
an issue of bulk and mass
it is quite a a bulky
although much improved
design my main concern i
like councillor lauren shaw
and chris stanley is with the parking
this shared parking area at the front
does seem to me to be a bit of a recipe
for disaster
when we as a committee visited the site
there there was a huge amount of
congestion
around the back there now the amount of
cars that were around there i don't
think that's going to
reduce now we're saying that there will
be
an issue with the go
which goes with the planning application
where there will be mitigation
for parking in the approach road there
but i'm not sure how they can do that
because it's not adopted
so the council certainly has nothing no
way of actually monitoring that
and certainly um uh
councillor stanley's point about the uh
shared spaces
uh being not available should the
residents come back is a serious issue
um i do although
as i say i do think that the developers
have done well
to try to address the issues that we've
raised
i don't think they've done enough so at
the moment
i'm afraid i still can't support this
application
thank you councillor wilson
thank you chairman um there's a couple
of points really it's it's
picking up on the point that uh
councillor wilkinson made
when we visited there it's true that um
it was a bright
sunny day um and it actually during a
period of
um little rain and it i was surprised
how damp it was
and so my question is from a legal point
of view
um if we were to approve this and
it it's likely that
the overshadowing would be greater we
would be exacerbating that problem
so where would we stand on that is there
any um
legal requirement for us to take that
into account and the other point which
was
made by councillor dre which was the
overlooking
i just wanted confirmation um from
katy rogers whether there is no
possibility
of any of the properties overlooking 6a
thank you thank you councillor fd
thank you chairman um just a couple of
things actually i actually
quite like this development i think it
would be very nice
for where it is because it's a very bad
sight at the moment but i've just got a
couple of uh
questions there seems very good report
done
by the officers but just seems to be a
couple things missing
it says in cases what she said earlier
the
parking management strategy i haven't
seen that anywhere i can't find any
reports on the addendums i don't know if
i've missed it
so i'd like some more information on
what that actually means and how it can
be
implemented and also the water runoff
it's saying on the report that the water
water's going to be reduced to 2.5
meters
2.5 liters per minute i think it's
minute or second from
between 9 and 30 liters that's great for
controlling that water but it also says
ethics county council and suds look
asking for more information
on the waterfalling on the roofs
runoff now that seems to be more
uncontrolled
and if that's being more uncontrolled
that will cause the dampness 27a
was as i'm saying before any strategy to
get most of the water actually in the
direction is really good
just like to know how what happens with
that water there's no reports coming in
yet
thank you thank you council steptoe
thank you chairman i'd like a little bit
of guidance from officers
on um on policy please
uh with regards from both either a
rochford district council policy and
national policy on the right
to light and overshadowing uh i can't
recall what the
national or local policy is on that so
can i have some clarification on that
please
thank you we'll sum these up in a second
council hawkway
thank you chairman um yes uh a couple of
things i'd like to
um ask katie in regards to this uh
this plan development um we
had a photograph of the um the wall
the the boundary wall um and um
i wondered whether that that wall is
going to be retained in its entirety
along the
boundary or whether it's going to be
modified in some way or another
and also um from the
diagram showing the the plan for the
development
um it seems that there is that one one
point of the building
is um very close to the boundary edge
uh and i wondered if katie could um
uh be able to inform us as to
what uh how close the building is to the
edge
of the boundary line and therefore to
that wall thank you
councillor williams thank you chairman
it does seem to me that the developers
in this have have
done everything that we've asked them to
do um i suspect that the
water situation will be improved with
this development and as much that
the surface water will go down into the
surface water drains as opposed to
running down the hill um parking is
as far as i can see is not really our
concern that's up to the uh
up up to the residents to to organize i
guess a parking company to look after
that for them
and i would like to say that i will
fully support this thank you
thank you councillor gooding
i just wondered if katie would be able
to clarify
uh the when they're the balconies are
they overlooking
the sites or are they
just balconies for show
thank you okay thank you right we've got
no other members indicating at the
moment
a variety of points have have been made
but in in particular the argument
around shadow and light um
has taken prominence so katie can i ask
you to sum up the various points and
questions that have been met
please thank you
um thank you
bear with me i'm just going to get um
the layout plan on the screen
it's great
bear with me right i'm going to share my
screen now
okay so what you should see on screen is
the proposed layout plan
um so i'm going to take your comments in
reverse order i think it might just be
easiest for me so counselor gooding
mentioned
and some clarity around balconies and
overlooking
so without i could bring up the um i'm
happy to bring up the elevations of both
just to give you sort of more sort of
certainty where the balconies are but
let me show you on this plan first
because this gives you
um you know an indication of where the
balconies are in relation to boundaries
and then for potential overlooking to
7a so on this building here where my
cursor is
we have balconies um here on this
elevation at first floor
um and on this elevation here at first
floor
so views out from each of these
balconies so the views from here would
be directed in this direction
and the the side of the balcony is
enclosed by part of the wall
to the elevation so if you were on this
balcony here
you would not be getting a view you know
back into the windows of 7a
equally here you know again you've got
an enclosing
um part of the wall to the balcony so
there's no opportunity
for looking that in that direction and
your views will be directed
um over this central green space here
again that's the same for the balconies
the extend
and further away from the boundary with
7a and so they're on this elevation here
indicated with my
cursor and then again in this location
here
so the balcony which caused the most i
guess concern during the course of the
application was the one to the first
floor in this built this flat here where
my cursor is
and that particular balcony would be
treated with this louvre detail and it
would extend
all the way across so when you're stood
on this balcony here you would
not be able to view in this direction
in this direction where my cursor is
indicating over to 7a
your view would be directed across the
site in this direction
because of the positioning of these
louvres
so you'd still get light into the
balcony so it would still be a space
that could be utilized
by any potential occupier um but it
would not allow for this
um overlooking here i hope that
clarifies that
um balcony issue
um in relation to the layout plan
um and councillor hookway's comments
about the proximity
um of this building to this boundary so
it's at this point here
that the building would be closest to
the boundary
and that is a distance of about 1.5
meters
increasing to 4 meters separation
in this area here
um with i won't bring up the photo of
the wall again
um unless anybody particularly needs me
to but
there is a condition requiring that the
boundary wall is retained
um if there is any requirement during
construction
for it to be demolished it must be um
a boundary wall must be re-erected um to
the same height
and that would be required to be agreed
um by the council
but i envisaged and it is proposed that
this existing boundary wall is retained
[Applause]
um
[Music]
counselor steptoe in terms of guidance
on policy in relation to right to light
and overshadowing
so um we have
a policy which talks about a 45 degree
angle i think which members will be
familiar with
but what that is designed to do okay so
if you
imagine this is a terrace of residential
properties and you were proposing a a
two-storey
rear extension here you would take a 45
degree angle
from the ground floor window on the
elevation in this direction
and if the rear extension breached that
we would have
concerns so whilst we have a
supplementary
planning guidance sort of policy
relating to that 45 degree angle
in terms of acceptable or unacceptable
overshadowing
that just relates to kind of proposed
rear extensions where properties are in
line with one another
and that doesn't you know give us
reference for this situation here
what we can go to is um guidance
in the ethics design guide which talks
about appropriate
um levels of daylight
to an existing property as a result
of new development and the essex design
guide
talk is clear that it's a 25 degree
angle we're talking about
taken at a point two meters um
above ground level on the property to be
to be considered and this diagram here
this this section diagram on screen
is what the applicant has provided to
demonstrate
that this building here would not breach
that 45 degree
angle so in terms of a policy reference
in terms of appropriate daylight to the
windows in the relevation of this
property
the proposal would meet the requirement
um in relation to overshadowing
there are no specific local or national
requirements that talk about limits that
are acceptable
or unacceptable in relation to
overshadowing
so it's accepted yes that this building
is going to cause some degree of
overshadowing
to this you know this space here um
and that is so most of this area here
where my cursor is is a patio
and we've seen in the photographs as
well to the rear of number 7a
and then there's an area of lawn my
cursor is here
so some overshadowing will result
there's no policy guidance to sort of
define a set limit that's unacceptable
um and what we need to do in in
consideration
of the impacts is consider sort of
things in the round
so it wouldn't be
the case that this area would be
overshadowed at all times at all times
of the year but yes there would be some
overshadowing it would change the
situation
that they currently experience what
we've borne in mind is the fact that
this garden
sorry this property does benefit from a
very substantial garden
so when we look at general acceptability
in terms of impacts of overshadowing
we're sort of taking a view in relation
to all the factors and if this was their
only area of garden
you know that would be you know a more
severe impact
than the situation which is that they
have a garden which extends
um here and all the way to the front of
the property it's a quite an unusual
plot in that it's a
detached property in the town center
set in very spacious um grounds
um and the the area to the front garden
somewhat unusually because usually front
gardens are um
lack privacy because they're on a street
frontage but that's not the case here
so the other areas of this property's
garden
um would not be affected and to the same
extent as this area here so
that that's what we bear in mind i hope
that's given you something but
in summary there is no sort of technical
limit in terms of the acceptability of
overshadowing
councillor fd um talked about um
water runoff and it's right to say that
in the report um there was a holding
objection from the lead local flood
authority
because um the applicant hadn't
um provided all the detail that the suds
team require in relation to treatment of
water off the roof
so the suds team are satisfied that
um all the water from the site
would and i'll go back to the layout
plan
oh i don't know well i'm gonna go sorry
bear with me i don't know why it does
that
let's see if i can
apologize right hopefully we'll get the
layout plan back so
in terms of the surface water drainage
strategy um
the only outstanding point that the
sustain did have
was with the treatment of the water and
that's to
to sort of make sure um that it's going
through
permeable paving essentially where it
meets um
so to to reduce pollutants if you like
but in terms of the actual water all of
the water from the site would be dealt
with by way of being directed to an
attenuation tank
and that attenuation tank would be
underneath the ground at approximately
this point here
um where this or vehicle access runs
underneath
this this building so all of the water
would be attenuated to the tank and then
all of the runoff would be controlled
um at um the controlled rates that were
set out in the report
so there would be betterment to the
situation in relation to surface water
drainage
um yeah all of the water would be taken
and and dealt with so in that respect i
think this might deal with some of the
other
issues we had with relation to the
overshadowing and the impacts in terms
of groundwater
the the sites going to be provided with
a surface water drainage strategy
attenuation tank controlled surface
water runoff rate
which would improve the situation and i
don't think there would be
a ground to refuse an application in
relation to an overshadowing impact
and the effect that that might have on
um
the the time it would take for lund to
dry out
in relation to to 7a um
[Music]
just
right now we're going back to i also
asked about the parking strategy
okay oh yeah sorry sorry you get council
actually sorry the parking strategy yes
so there isn't a parking management
strategy submitted or set out
um so what we have acknowledged
is that there are here
um can you see my cursor here so because
of the layout
you know people i think would be
discouraged
from blocking in formally designated
bays when this site
is developed because at the moment
people yes park in an ad hoc basis down
this
turning head because this is a backland
site and
and nobody is accessing it nobody's
around there
um and nobody's sort of control
controlling this situation in any way
once this site is developed i think
there will be a disincentive for people
to pop blocking in what is a designated
bay
and there may well be signage put up as
well so i think that the the
layout of the site designs out the
problem here
it doesn't the layout deal with the fact
that people sometimes park
here and partly over the pavement
um and in the street um so what the
section 106
heads of terms will require is not only
the resurfacing
of this um but a parking management
strategy
to be agreed now that may well be um
in this particular area here some
signage and
some markings on the the road in
particular here to say
no parking um and that would be
controlled by
um you know it would be a private
managed
um strategy um you know like what
happens in sort of private
areas with clamping um uh
and fines etc um but you're right it
wouldn't be the adopted highway
authority
um and the local parking parking
partnership controlling this
um it would be private but there but
there would be a requirement for this
strategy to be developed and agreed
in the 106 agreement and the applicant
has already been in discussions with the
owners um of the access um to talk about
um those requirements um and
and they would the owners would be
required to sign up to the 106 as well
um
katie
just yet bear with me i'm just looking
back at my notes
um there was uh
um
[Music]
i think there were some comments with
regard to where water was going
hopefully i've addressed those they are
at paragraph 3.75 and 3.76 of the report
in relation to surface water drainage
and there would be
some conditions imposed um it wasn't
timely for the addendum
but the lead local flood authority have
now accepted
that the outstanding requirement in
terms of just the treatment
of the water and really that's a
requirement that it when it falls off
the roof
it go through some um permeable paving
before it then enter the attenuation
tank because it's
it's introducing more layers of
treatment to that water before it goes
into the drains
um they're satisfied that that can be
achieved
so they're happy to look at the um
impose the conditions
yeah sorry there are some disabled bays
um hopefully you can see those in the
center of the site here
so the additional width um is is
provided to each side
and to the
thank you i think uh i think i've ticked
off virtually everything
members we we've had a detailed
presentation tonight
we've had two site visits we had the
benefit of a previous
meeting where this was discussed in
detail
the planning application is the planning
application
for one reason or another you may or may
not like
some of the issues but i do believe that
we have had
more than enough information to help us
make a decision about whether
it is appropriate for planning a plan
commission to be given
or not on this application are there any
fresh points that any members have got
uh got got to make on this rather than
just restating the points
that we've we've already got
german may i speak please cancer stanley
thank you um just to reiterate what uh
katie said when it goes into the
attenuation tank where does it go
from there and also
the parking i don't believe
has been uh settled
and until that parking area is settled
i don't think but i personally that i
don't think
it's going to be a viable area
yes you've made that point i'm not sure
the
the direction of the flow of the
drainage
where is the water going from when it
goes into the attenuation temperature
we wouldn't have it's been happened okay
thank you so
much councillor williams it's going to
go into the
rain or the water uh that's work or
whatever i don't believe it does
i don't think it is appropriate that
that we need to know
the actual direction of flow that the
site exists
the drainage exists there's attenuation
to the existing i'll just give k
katy time to just give an answer to that
before we move on
now it's only just german that where it
goes from there that's the point
if it goes into the ground then then 7a
will be absolutely flooded for a long
period of time thank you
okay to confirm the the the water from
the site
will be collected in a tenure in an
attenuation tank
and that water will then go to a public
surface water sewer
at a controlled rate
not to the ground thank you thank you
katie
all right members there is a
recommendation for approval
printed on 6.1
going through to 6.7 with some
informatives
there is information on the addendum
um there's information regarding
the removal of condition 17 sub
which would mean um i mean there's a
section 106
agreement in place that
would need to be agreed prior to first
occupation so all in all
i believe we're in a position to now
go to the vote uh katie could you stop
sharing please then i can
properly see all the members as we go
through the next stage
okay then so as as per usual members
um i'll ask you whether you're
in favor or not of the recommendation
and also if you want a recorded vote but
just before we
we start the process can i just double
check that
no one has been cut off or missed any
elements of the
discussion before we make a decision
okay right here we go then
council butcher
yes thank you um yeah
um yeah i don't need a recorded vote
and i approve councillor fd
thank you chairman nobody called he'd
vote and i for approval please
thank you councillor eves recorded the
vote and against the proposal
thank you councillor gooding
no recorded vote and approved the
development thank you
councillor hawkway
recorded vote and against
cancer record of vote and against
thank you councillor merrick
no recorded vote and for approval thank
you
cancer mr shaw
sorry no recorded vote and against
council stanley
a recorded vote and against due to the
fact we
didn't approve of it last time because
of that
i just need to know yes or no can you
just confirm for or against
against henry called you please thank
you cancer steptoe
no recorded vote and approve thank you
councillor williams thank you chairman
no record to vote and for the approval
thank you councillor wilson
uh recorded vote and against chairman
thank you
nearly forgot myself no recorded vote
and four
i believe that is carried seven six
six did you just confirm that son
sonia yeah okay thank you that item
is approved
next we have uh land
fronting car park access bellingham lane
railing yeah with your permission i'm
going to leave the meeting that's okay
thank you thank you
katie i believe you're going to present
on this one again please
sorry yes thank you um just sharing my
screen
so members should see on screen a
location plan
so this application is for the
installation of a rapid electric vehicle
charging point
the equipment is proposed to be
installed on part of the pedestrian
footwear
adjacent to the carriageway on on
bellingham lane
take you to the layout plan
so the equipment will be cited um
sorry so this top plan is an aerial
image with
two parking bays superimposed and just
in a very faint red but where my cursor
is here
this is the proposed location um of the
equipment
so the equipment will be sited some 5.7
meters from
from this end of the central island and
close to the edge of the footway
the concrete base um is shown with the
white
in here so the bottom diagram is the
same
um pedestrian island and with the drop
curve where my cursor is here
and here and this is the area of
proposed installation of equipment so
the white
area is the concrete base the
rectangular area here
is the proposed um charging unit and
this um
other rectangular shape to the side
is the feeder pillar so a gap of 1.75
meters
of the pedestrian footwear would be
retained behind the equipment
and the intention is that vehicles would
park in these two bays on the
carriageway
um to use the charging point
i'll just take you to the next plan
so the charging unit is shown in the top
right hand corner
of the plan on the screen here where my
cursor is this is the front elevation
and then this is the side elevation
so the unit would have a height of 1.8
meters and a width of 41
centimeters and the feeder pillar is
shown in the bottom right hand corner of
the plan
and would have a height of 1.2 meters
and a width of one meter
i take you back to bear with me the
location plan the
this area of bellingham lane up to the
junction with london hill to the north
um and extending south along high street
is within rayleigh conservation area
there are no nationally listed buildings
close to the application
site but number 20 20 to 22
high street which is in this area here
is locally listed and backs onto
bellingham lane opposite the application
site
there is a landscaped pedestrian space
to the west of the site from which the
proposed equipment would be visible
however the backdrop when viewed from
the open space would be towards the rear
of premises which front the high street
and it's the frontage of these premises
that hold the most value in terms of
character and appearance of the
conservation area
the rear elevations of these buildings
um do not make a positive contribution
i'll show you some street scenes so if
we just skip past the two plans i've
already shown you
so the first is a street scene
of the application site an immediate
surrounding area in this first image the
central island
is here um and you can see the rear of
the premises that front the high street
and the green space to the right-hand
side the proposed equipment would be
installed on the central island
approximately adjacent to where the red
car in the image is parked
with two proposed parking bays either
side of this
and then the second image
is viewed northwards along bellingham
lane and the silver car
where the curse is pointing is
approximately adjacent where the
equipment will be installed
the carriageway in this location is some
6.6 meters in width and space
would therefore be retained on the
carriageway adjacent to the proposed
parking bay
sufficient for a delivery lorry refused
lorry to pass
the proposal would introduce features
which would not be of any particular
design merit however given the location
it is considered that the proposal would
not result in unacceptable harm
to the character and appearance of the
conservation area space for pedestrians
to use the central island would still be
retained
with the proposed equipment in place and
there is no objection to the proposed
harm from the highways authority
the proposal would be of benefit in
terms of encouraging
use of electric vehicles which would be
a benefit to air quality
and which has been poor in the locality
the high street is commonly designated
as an air quality management area
and so this would help this situation
the recommendation
um is one of approval subject to the
recommended conditions
and a legal agreement to require the
applicant to pay for a traffic
regulation order
relating to the proposal and the base
within the carriageway
okay thank you katie can you can i just
ask you to
just make it absolutely clear about the
content of the
this application the application being
for
the charging points and the status of
the
proposed parking bays that would be
consequential
that go with this please yep so
um you wouldn't need planning permission
um
to put the the parking bays in the
highway
but it would be a matter that would have
to be addressed by a traffic regulation
order
separate to the planning consent if
granted
so the planning consent itself is
actually for the physical works of
putting this concrete base into the
footway
um sorry this the concrete base is is
the larger rectangle
um with this central rectangular um
charging point in it the feeder base
along feed the pillar alongside
um there's a signage pillar denoted by
that circle here
and just above you can see what the sign
is going to say um and then there is two
bollards just protecting the feeder
pillar
um adjacent to the carriageway so it's
these works
within the foot way that are the subject
of the application
thank you um i haven't noted any of our
non-members indicating at this point
so therefore we'll move straight on to
the members
side of the debate this is councillor
stanley first
thank you chair um katie uh
just a couple of little questions really
um
i notice you've got four well at the
moment there are double yellow lines so
you can't park down there
um are we then going to have
um
parking bays that is you i think you
showed four parking bays two of which
will be electric
but then if there is a delivery lorry
adjacent to those parking bays
how is traffic going to get through
would it not be
wiser and i put this down as a
helpful hint is to
make the parking bays half road half
on that council standing you know can i
stop you there
i'm gonna ask another question if you
can just stop there please counsel
stanley
um uh the officers just made it clear
that the application that is in front of
us
yeah is for an electric charging point
the parking bays are a separate issue
and what what it is for us to do i just
need to be clear on i just wanted to be
i just wanted cancer stanley place yeah
good
yeah and the planning application is the
planning application
that is what we're determining it is not
for us to make suggestions about
what the applicant whether it be rdc or
not might like to do at some future
stage
we must focus on the planning
application before us
yeah and that is specifically charging
points
yes it's just that i don't want to find
ourselves kicking this up the back side
when it's in the wrong place so okay
thank you
okay thank you cancer steptoe
thank you chairman uh just a couple of
um
items to clarification first of all uh
is does there need to be any
archaeological uh
issues around with regards to this
because of where
uh this is quite quite close to the um
uh radio mount that was my first
question
now where the electrical units will
stand
uh looking at the picture of the red car
uh the users are going to be
little way into the pavement area
they won't be right up against the curb
edge
and then cables will be run from that
those units to the vehicles what will
there be
to stop pedestrians walking between
the parked vehicle and the charger unit
where the cables will be run perhaps
you know i'm thinking of somebody that
is perhaps uh blind
uh perhaps he's not so good at uh site
or people just not paying attention
in between the vehicle and the uh
and the child unit on the patent thank
you
council mr shaw
thank you chair am i right katie can you
answer this i'm already saying that
essex county council highways have got
no issues with this please
because it hasn't been mentioned and i
might have missed it in the report thank
you
okay i haven't got any other members
indicating at the moment so
if you wouldn't mind dealing with those
questions please
um okay so in reverse order essex county
council
highways do not object to this
application um
[Music]
so that they're they're they're happy in
principle with it
um in terms of cancer steptoes concern
about the um
the actual charging sort of connections
and trailing
so if this let me just zoom in to this
um
just bring this down i think this
diagram is possibly
clearer than the image
okay so hopefully you can see this is a
zoomed in
section of the layout so
the white um rectangle
that is my cursor is just sort of going
around
is going to be a concrete base on which
the feeder unit will sit
and the actual connections
um would come out of this side so the
carriageway
side of the charging unit um
and then you plug in to the car
so there isn't any proposal for any sort
of bollards or railing around the back
of the unit but if i go back then to
um let me just go to i think it's plan
three
um this plan you'll see that the actual
it's on the front of the unit um that
this kind of um
i can't i can't think of the word but
the um
the um the the the plug-in the sort of
cable
would come out at the front of the unit
so i don't think there would be
a chance of it sort of trailing behind
the unit
and it's the area behind the unit that
would be the area maintained for
pedestrians to walk
along this this central island
in terms of archaeological issues we
haven't had um
any consultation response to say that
any works are required
um i don't think that um
the works are well they're kind of quite
small scale so i do understand the um
proximity um of kind of known historical
assets
um but we haven't had a response from
essex county council to say
that they require any archaeological um
work um before this um developments
carried out
thank you and that that depth from the
back of the charger to the road i think
i read it seventeen hundred and
fifty millimeters can i come back
yeah yes cancer scepter yeah uh katie
could you enlarge that to bottom section
of the drawing again
around where the charger unit is please
thank you katie um i i'm not sure if i
made myself
uh completely clear uh i accept the fact
that uh
to the top of the picture where it says
1500 to there
that area there is not going to have any
cables trailing across and that will be
open pavement
my concern was where the little arrow is
there
that area there if the whole thing is
going to be on a plinth
and there will be cables coming from the
front of that unit
going at diagonal angles to the two
vehicles path there
what is there to stop a pedestrian
that's perhaps
that has difficult seeing or is blind
or just somebody not paying attention
um being able to walk between
the charger unit and where that yellow
box
is what would that be
that they're happening and again if it's
on a plinth there'll be a step there as
well
so um so if you were coming from this
direction so from the north and going
along
this area um there's a bollard here
okay so there's a bollard here and then
this in total is 750 so the space
between there to actually
go around that bollard you'd have to
sort of it'd be quite difficult to
maneuver around there so i think the
ballard would be sufficient
to stop people from going in front
of the um the unit from that side and
then on this side
you've not only got a bollard here but
you've got this feeder unit as well
um that's positioned to the side so if
you like that would be
um you know what maybe not visible
if you're visually impaired but you
would come across this feeder unit
before you sort of tripped over any
any hazard and i don't think it's it's
now fairly narrow
i don't think people would be walking um
across this frontage
um so i do still have a concern
about impaired people being able to uh
uh with the train of cables there to be
a to
for it to give a concern i would like to
have seen something a little bit more
positive
i mean it is a council application
so whether or not it's a comment or an
informative we could put on
if members were minded to approve to
recommend that you know considerations
given to
to additional kind of um you know
treatment
to mean that people can't um you know
get get through this front area
potentially i think that's eminently
sensible but could i just make a
suggestion there that perhaps
if this application is approved that
the um applicant dis discusses that
particular issue
with the uh organization the blind
organizers can't think what it's called
the acronym for
it um the royal society for blind but
just to make sure that that is going to
be acceptable
of course that members the
recommendation for repro
approval is printed on 7.1
and 7.2 um
if you wouldn't mind stopping sharing
again katie so as i can see everyone's
screen
um our just uh members confirm that
you've all
heard all of the information no one's
lost anything part way through
so you're in a position to carry out
the vote
so um we shall begin
so as usual um does that include that
information with the import with the
informative as we've
highlighted with reference to the blind
organisation
um councillor smith um cancer stanley's
indicating
cancer stanley
thank you chairman um does this uh could
could katie
clarify a little pointer will the yellow
line still be
there or not thank you
i i've got to intervene there the yellow
lines are a highways issue not part of
the planning application
okay um
so if if you members you would indicate
whether you wish to have a recorded vote
and then whether you are for or against
the application
council butcher yes thank you
no recorded vote and for the application
that's the fd
now we call you voting for the
application please counselor eaves
for the application councillor gooding
no recorded vote and for the application
very recorded vote and again
can't say oh no no recorder vote
and for merrick
no and councillor shaw
no and for cancer stanley
recorded vote and against that's the
step toe
no and for the application that's the
williams
chairman no and for the application
council wilson
no and for chairman and myself
no and four that application
is approved thank you very much for that
one members
item eight st john fisher recreation
ground little weekly chase
rayleigh katie is again presenting for
us
thank you
i'll just share my screen with you now
so this application is for the siting of
a storage container on part of a
recreation ground
the site of the pros container is edged
red on the location plan just
point my curse is pointing at the site
now um
position towards the northern boundary
the proposed container would be a
standard design and some six meters in
length by 2.3 meters in width
it will be painted dark green
so this photograph is a view towards
that part of the site on which the
container is proposed to be cited
and the photo shows the area where the
container will be cited
in more detail in the next image this is
just further in
and it would be adjacent just adjacent
to the edge of this car parking area
and close extending close to this
boundary of the site here
the site is within the green belt
however the container would be required
in relation to use of the wider site for
outdoor recreation as a storage facility
in relation to use of the site as
football pitches
in this regard the proposal would
therefore be considered appropriate
development within the greenbelt
the size of the proposed container would
not be considered excessive for the
proposed use
there's no concern in relation to any
other issues of residential amenity
and the recommendation is there for one
of approval subject to the recommended
conditions
thank you
um uh i'm not
noting any non-members wishing to
speak i'm not even noting any
members wishing to speak therefore we'll
go
straight to the vote uh the
um was cancer stanley have you indicated
yeah yes uh yes thank you thank you
chairman um is it is the
proposed site going to be on the
green part of the are we talking about
on that green
portion of land on the side
i don't know if i'm muted or not let me
just
can you hear me yes yes sorry um
let me share my screen again i thought i
thought you'd just shown us fairly
sorry for clarity and so what you can
see is the red line
here with the curse around it that's the
um proposed container
and then this line here the sort of gray
dashed line
is the extent of the sort of car parking
area um so it's it's on the grassed area
um so in this image um it's just
beyond and that bin there and it's in
this area extending
up to the boundary so it's on the grass
okay right thank you so that's clear for
everyone so
um there's a recommendation printed on
8.1
uh and a little bit on 8.2
everyone is fully informed has heard the
presentation and
is ready to vote if you could just stop
sharing again please
thank you as usual um
whether you'd like a recorded vote and
whether you're for or against
the proposal counselor butcher
thank you no recorded vote and for the
proposal cancer fd
nobody called you voting for the
proposal thank you chairman eves
sorry i i missed that councillor aves no
and four thank you councillor gooding
no recorded vote m4 thank you okay
uh no recorded vote and four
councillor no no recorded vote and four
councillor merrick oh and
thank you chairman that's the stanley
no n4 thank you thank you cancer steptoe
no and four thank you councillor
williams
thank you chairman that's no n4
councillor wilson
no and four chairman myself no
and four that is a unanimous approval
for that
application there are no items referred
from the weekly list so at
8 58 that brings us to the end
thank you very much members